io sono un entomologo cioè uno studioso
di insetti ma sono specializzato
nell'ecologia decorazione è quella
scienza che studia le relazioni tra gli
organismi viventi e il loro ambiente
esistono dei fili invisibili che
sorreggono gli ecosistemi che mantengono
gli ecosistemi in equilibrio e quindi
permettono alla vita di andare avanti
ebbene questi fili si sono rotti questi
figli si sono spezzati attualmente
stiamo vivendo una crisi ambientale
davvero grave
talmente grave che secondo alcuni
scienziati
siamo prossimi alla fine della nostra
specie homo sapiens
ma quando è iniziata questa crisi
secondo alcuni scienziati la crisi
iniziata con la comparsa dell'homo
sapiens a con la nostra specie
fin da subito ci siamo messi così in
vetta le catene alimentari e fin da
subito abbiamo provocato l'estinzione di
tanti animali e in particolare la mega
la megafauna che è così solcava i
continenti del mondo
altri invece dicono che no tutti gli
ecosistemi tutti gli ambienti in qualche
modo subiscono delle crisi tutte le
specie interagiscono con l'ambiente ed è
normale che alcune specie più forti
portino all'estinzione di altri secondo
questi scienziati la vera crisi è
iniziata nel 1775 quando vuote
uno studioso inventa la prima macchina a
vapore dando vita alla prima rivoluzione
suonando mita alla rivoluzione
industriale la le industrie hanno
portato tantissimi manufatti nel nostro
mondo ma anche tante inquinamenti e
soprattutto dato che le fabbriche e le
industrie sono energivore c'è un eccesso
e tanta energia hanno emesso tan tan ed
carbonica nell'atmosfera che sapete per
produrre l'energia
bisogna in qualche modo produrre anche
contestualmente tanta anidride carbonica
altri scienziati dicono che l'inizio
della fine avvenuta il 27 agosto del
1859 quando il colonnello drake e che
rata era un ferroviere lascia scalfire
la superficie terrestre ea prelevare il
petrolio a 25 metri di profondità questa
sostanza antichissima questa sostanza
preistorica e incontra una invenzione
moderna nel 1908 incontro infatti la
ford t nera la prima automobile
costruita seguendo la catena di
montaggio è la rivoluzione della
mobilità umana il mondo diventa immagine
somiglianza dell'automobile pensate che
attualmente esiste una rete stradale di
64 milioni di chilometri
è come fare un viaggio terra luna per
170 volte e quindi una frammentazione
gli ecosistemi una distruzione degli
ambienti eccetera eccetera ma queste
strade sono solcate da un miliardo e 200
mila automobili cioè quasi il doppio
della popolazione europea macchine che
inquinano macchine che producono co2 che
è la è un gas serra che produce è il
primo responsabile del riscaldamento
globale il quale rompe i sottili fidel
della natura che porta una disastro
ambientale
alcuni invece sostengono che l'inizio
della fine si è avvenuta nel 1869 quando
il chimico height trova una diciamo così
un una soluzione per impiegare la
celluloide primo materiale plastico
costruisce le palle da biliardo
sostituisce lavori o con questa sostanza
plastica la plastica un materiale
incredibile meraviglioso con le quali si
possono fare tantissime cose a un
problema non si degrada non è
biodegradabile e quindi ha iniziato a
invadere il nostro mondo pensate che
secondo alcuni scienziati se continuiamo
a gettare la plastica con lo stesso
ritmo attuale nel 2050 negli oceani ci
saranno più ci sarà più plastica che
pesci altri ancora invece sostengono
cleanse alla fine si al 1930 al 1939
quando john miller
chimico svizzero scopre l'efficacia
insetticida debiti una molecola in
realtà scoperta un secolo prima
benelli di ti offre un tassello
importantissimo per la cosiddetta in
cultura industriale la quale
parafrasando il mio maestro giorgio
celli ha eseguito un vero e proprio
attentato alla biodiversità
ma perché sono così importanti questi
fili della natura perché dobbiamo
preservarli lo racconto con un animale
che probabilmente che voi di ferrara
conoscete bene la zanzara in realtà
questa fortunatamente non la conoscete
xkè la zanzara anofele mandarano offre
la zanzara che veicola una pericolosa
malattia che è la malaria è l'animale
più pericolosa al mondo molto più
pericoloso del leone degli altri grandi
predatori bene questa zanzara sapete
stata radicata nel nostro territorio c'è
stata eliminata nel 1943 dai dagli
alleati che hanno spruzzato per la prima
volta al mondo il ddt proprio in italia
per togliere di mezzo questa pericolosa
da andare quindi alla malattia
bene nel 1950 questa zanzara e ha però
era presente ed abbondante nell'isola
del borneo
sapete l'isola incastonate nei mari del
sud est asiatico e per eliminare questo
terribile parassita gli inglesi che
all'epoca governavano l'isola decidono
di scaricare sugli aerei delle delle
norme taniche di viti e di far piovere
questa sostanza sull'isola è successo è
clamoroso la zanzara scompare e con lei
la malaria tutto bene quel che finisce
bene direte invece no
dopo esattamente tre mesi tutte le case
del borneo iniziano a crollare cos'era
successo
un mistero fittissimo nessuno ci capiva
niente tant'è che i governi inglese
decide di chiamare una categoria di
professionisti nota per la loro grande
intelligenza grande capacità nel
risolvere il problema sono anche
piuttosto figli e diciamo sono gli
entomologi categoria ha casualmente
casualmente faccio parte e quali
immediatamente chiara
capiscono il problema capiscono che il
dt aveva da una parte eliminata la
zanzara
ma dall'altra vele minato una vespina in
parassitoide si chiama il quale inietta
un nuovo all'interno degli ospiti in
particolare di alcuni bruchi dal nuovo
voce una piccola l'arma che si mangia
come un piccolo alien l'ospite
dall'interno uccidendolo
quindi senza la vespina le popolazioni
di bruchi e non aumentata a dismisura e
il cibo preferito dei bruchi e non erano
il bambù le canne di bambù il principale
materiale costruttivo della del del
borneo quindi letteralmente le case non
state ingoiate divorate da questi bruchi
bene into molo ge oltre a essere
intelligenti eccetera eccetera e ci sono
anche estremamente pratici questo sano e
quindi decidono allevare la vespina in
laboratorio e liberaria nel territorio
ma esattamente dopo tre mesi una
terribile epidemia di tifo si scatena
sull'isola cosa è successo
ovviamente nessuno ci capisce niente e
ovviamente di nuovo governo inglese
decide di chiamare una categoria di
professionisti particolarmente
intelligente praticamente capace e
chiama gli entomologi il quale
ovviamente capiscono subito allora il
ddt aveva ucciso la zanzara aveva ucciso
la vestina i bruchi erano aumentati in
maniera leggermente intossicati con la
sostanza insetticida il principale
predatore dei bruchi ne mangiava
tantissimi ci nero così tanti che aveva
un banchetto e norma disposizione ma a
causa del fenomeno delle bioaccumulo sin
tossica va la dose ingerita di ddt non
era sufficiente ad ucciderlo ma a
rimbecillire lo e quindi il geco scusate
eccolo qua il geco che è il principale
predatore dei bruchi se ne stava pollai
ato fermo sui sassi al sole alla mercè
del suo principale nemico che è il gatto
gatti mangiavano tutti i gechi questa
volta sempre per il bioaccumulo la
quantità di ritira talmente elevata che
i gatti iniziano
senza i gatti cosa succede i topi
ballano e ballano pure le pulci del topo
le quali vanno sulle persone e così
veicolavano la terribile malattia del
tifo come risolve la situazione chi
chiamare perché eccetera eccetera e gli
entomologi e quali così consigliano al
governatore del borneo di mandare
inviare i soldati nella vicina india
raccattare raccogliere tutti i gatti
dell'india portarli nel borneo e
liberarli per appunto salvare
ristabilire l'equilibrio bene ma un
nuovo problema così incombe sull'isola
del borneo come distribuire i gatti in
un'isola impervia
siamo nel 1950 quindi non c'era ancora
le strade bisogna per forza chiamare una
categoria di professionisti capace di
risolvere grandi problemi e sono 100
niente è che risolvono tutti i problemi
gli entomologi chiamano gli ingegneri
che sono un livello un po più basso
degli entomologi ora non si può non
posso fa tutti gli entomologi gli
ingegneri inventa uno speciale
paracadute per gatto e fu così che il 24
giugno del 1952
scatta l'operation al cat drop 12 mila
gatti vengono paracadutati nell'isola
del borneo e ristabiliscono l'equilibrio
bene velocemente che racconta un'altra
storia sull'importanza del degli
equilibri e di questi fili invisibili la
natura nel 1950 sapete l'australia viene
colonizzata dagli inglesi quali portano
in questo nuovo continente le mandrie di
mucche queste mucche iniziano a mangiare
e mangiare a mangiare e ovviamente una
dieta ricca in fibra produce una lauta
così produzione di escrementi e iniziano
a farla adeguatamente anche in australia
ma in australia successa una cosa
davvero straordinaria
gli escrementi non venivano processati
cioè permanevano sul prato come mai
tutto il resto del mondo ovviamente gli
esperimenti vanno via libici rimanevano
rimani oggi rimani domani rimani per
decenni si arriva al 1900 in cui
l'australia era letteralmente ricoperta
di escrementi
vi lascio immaginare i problemi l'odore
eccetera eccetera
una situazione molto grave voglio dire
la stazione gravissima che necessita
l'intervento di professionisti molto
capaci molto bravi molto intelligenti e
pur esperti della materia sono gli
entomologi che stava finendo molla gli
entomologi capiscono che mancava in
australia un tassello un filo della
natura eder ascoli 8 loster corà
stercorario con l'altro stercoraro un
animale molto bello si nutre
esclusivamente di sterco degli erbivori
addirittura non beve l'acqua l'assume
dal suo alimento preferito e quindi
capiscono che non veniva processati
escrementi perché mancavano questi
insetti in realtà c'era uno dei
coleotteri stella corani australia
merano abituati a così agli escrementi
dei koala e dei canguri ben poca roba
rispetto ai 25 kg di produzione
quotidiana della mucca quindi gli
entomologi decidono di andare in giro
per il mondo a cercare il campione del
mondo della sua specialità
cioè uno che si mangia lo sterco appunto
vanno in giro dappertutto lo trovano
e lo trovano in sudamerica di scusate in
sudafrica perché trovano il coleottero
abituato a processare gli escrementi
dell'elefante che ne fa ben 50 kg al
giorno lo porto in australia lo liberano
e dopo soli 4 anni
l'australia ritorna a verde di nuovo si
sente il profumo di violette
pensate che gli australiani grati di
dicono al coleottero stercorario una
statua che è un'enorme sfera di sterco
viaggiano di coleotteri stercorari
ammetto che non è molto elegante non è
bellissima però è doverosa ma siamo
davvero a linee all
alla fine davvero noi abbiamo rotto
tutti gli equilibri e quindi siamo
prossime all'estinzione
proviamo a vedere a risponderci con
questo animale strano
ordinario
lui è il gipeto delle alpi è appunto un
uccello bellissimo un'apertura alare
pensate di tre metri ea tra virgolette
un difetto è un avvoltoio c'è si nutre
di cadaveri e quindi il gipeto come
tutti gli avvoltoi nel mondo veniva
considerato un animale sporco vicino al
demonio peccaminose eccetera eccetera e
quindi veniva sterminato in italia come
dappertutto addirittura cavallo tra
l'ottocento e il novecento
c'è una taglia governo italiano fornita
va dei soldi a chi riusciva ad uccidere
il gipeto delle alpi spara oggi spara
domani si arriva al 1913 in cui viene
ucciso l'ultimo gipeto delle alpi in val
di rally in val d'aosta
da quel momento il volo straordinario di
questo uccello scompare dalle alpi
passano gli anni arrivano gli anni 80
nasce una nuova scienza che l'ecologia
applicata che vuole riconnettere i fili
invisibili la natura e alcuni
naturalistiche in qualche modo
appartengono alle nazioni che si
affacciano al via sulle alpi si
ritrovano in svizzera per studiare un
progetto per riportare il gipeto sulle
alpi
l'idea è insomma complicata ma
realistica bisognava andare bisogna
andare sul in pakistan e in india dove
ancora viveva e vive il gipeto prelevare
delle uova in a picasso ovviamente sulle
cime inaccessibili prendere le uova
andare negli zoo allevare i pulcini
portare i pulcini sulle alpi prima però
costruire dei nidi artificiali puoi
sperare che il gipeto potesse in qualche
modo riprendersi propria reale
tutto bene quel che finisce bene gli
ultimi minuti però del convegno sono
davvero imbarazzanti
c'è un
non da d'imbarazzo sochi partecipanti
perché gli svizzeri capofila del
progetto presentano il conto svariati
milioni di euro
ovviamente non c'è o gli euro ma è solo
una una quota una quantità di denaro
davvero considerevole
gli austriaci decidono subito di pagare
i francesi store con un po il naso poi
alla fine fino agli assegni arriva il
turno degli italiani e qua a campo non
può di scuse dicono l'inflazione c'è per
eccetera e non partecipano alla
reintroduzione del gipeto sulle alpi
cioè non pagano una lira non sborsano un
soldo per tutti gli anni 90 i
naturalisti dai paesi del nord
ovviamente fanno in india mani in
pakistan si arrampicano sui picchi
inaccessibili prendono le uova le
portano negli zolle lavorano un sacco
spendono tantissimi soldi ma il loro
sforzo viene ricompensato perché il
nuovo millennio viene salutato dal volo
straordinario di questo uccello
tutto bene quel che finisce bene passano
agli anni arriva al 2001 2002 2003
arriva il fatidico 2006 quando una
coppia di gipeti francesi inizia a
volare pericolosamente ed illegalmente
verso l'italia se fa un voletto in
italia poi torni indietro
figuratevi francesi dopo tutto quello
che hanno speso dopo tutto quello che ha
lavorato secondo una leggenda
metropolitana che così circola nei
corridoi degli istituti di scienze
naturali i francesi presero delle
carcasse animali e misero vicino ai nidi
dei cpt per trattenerli nel suolo
francese
lo stratagemma funziona nel 2007 perché
i gipeti rimangono in in francia ma nel
2008 succede quel che non doveva
succedere
la stessa coppia di gipeti di nuovo va
verso l'italia farc al confine e non
solo va in italia ma nidifica pure e
nidifica in val d'herens dove era stato
ucciso l'ultimo gipeto delle alpi da
quel momento ci fu un proprio esodo
sacco centinaia di uccelli dalla parte
nord se sono trasferite a sud e adesso
siamo nel 2019 e l'italia vanta la più
alta popolazione di gipeti di tutto
l'arco alpino
senza fa senza fare niente e senza
sborsare una lira come si dice però al
di là delle facili battute faceva tutte
questa storia ci dice una cosa ci dice
che la natura ha una sua forza la natura
ai 4 milioni e 4 miliardi e mezzo di
anni ha una sua forza incredibile
e se in qualche modo gli lasciamo lo
spazio l'essere riprende e quindi
secondo me
secondo la mia opinione non siamo alla
fine ma siamo all'inizio di una nuova
era l'era in cui l'uomo riuscirà
riconnette se riconciliarsi con la
natura a riconnettere quei fili
invisibili che raccontano una storia
meravigliosa la nostra grazie
[Applauso]